The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TOMER ULLMAN: And today,
with your active help
and participation, I hope to
run a probabilistic programming
tutorial in the time
that we have left.
And we're going to
focus specifically
on a language
called Church, which
is a probabilistic programming
language that was developed
in Josh Tenenbaum's
Group, but it's
now taken on a life of
its own and has set up
shop in other places.
Before I get started,
I should say,
I was, sort of, looking
for a good image.
I didn't like a
blank page, so I was
googling just Church tutorial.
This is the first thing I found.
It's an image for
Minecraft about how
to build a church in Minecraft.
Does any of us--
people have heard of Minecraft?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TOMER ULLMAN: They've
played with Minecraft?
OK-- just in case
you don't know,
Minecraft is a sort of
procedurally-generated world
where you get some
building blocks, literally,
building blocks, that
you can build stuff with.
And you can build an infinite
number of things, including
a computer, and a church.
And it's very cool.
And I thought it's
actually not that
bad of an image for a tutorial
about probabilistic programming
language, which is
also about, sort
of, procedurally-generative
things that
use small building blocks
to build up an entire world.
And I thought, OK, that's
the first hit I got.
What's the other hit?
Well, it's just another
church, and another church,
and another church, another
church, another church
that you can build in Minecraft
from many different angles
and many different tutorials,
so maybe, instead of this,
you can just train some
deep-learning algorithm
to, I don't know, learn a
billion churches and do that.
That's not what we're after.
So probabilistic
programming, Josh already
talked a bunch
about this, so I'll
sort of be repeating
him, or channeling him.
It's about combining
the best of both worlds
in the, sort of,
two states of AI
right now, which is
statistical modeling and logic.
And in many models,
you have this,
sort of, dual question of
representation and learning.
And it's really, sort of, a
problem for cognitive science,
going back to the days of
before cognitive science, right?
I mean, this is the sort of
problem that a lot of people
had when they tried to
model the human mind.
This goes back to Turing.
Sort of, when we want
to build a system that
is human-like in
its intelligence,
the two questions
that we face are,
what are the representations
that it will have,
and how is it
going to learn them
or how is it going to
learn anything new?
And you often have
to, sort of-- it's
a short blanket problem, right?
If you try to cover
your head, your feet
are sort of not
getting anything.
If you try to cover
your feet, your head's
not getting anything.
Because oftentimes, you
find that, if you stick
to a particularly easy
representation that's
sort of easy to code
or rather something,
a kind of a presentation
that's easy to learn,
like say a vector of weights
that you're just trying
to shift your weights
around, then, yes, that
might be easy, relatively
easy, but you're
sort of stuck with
the representation
that you can learn are weights.
Or Josh was making a
big point about this,
and it is a big point, that
if you try to learn something
like causal Bayes nets,
then you're sort of limited
by that representation.
That is your representation
of these sort
of circles and arrows that
go into other circles.
And that might get
you very, very far.
And you might even have very
good learning algorithms
for those particular
models, for those particular
representations,
that are tailored
for those representations.
Like, in these causal
circles and arrows,
belief propagation might be a
very good learning algorithm,
but if you commit to
that representation,
then you are sort of stuck
with that representation.
And you might not
be flexible enough
to learn all the stuff
that you want to.
And a very flexible
representation, sort of,
one of the more
flexible ones that
have come onto the
scene in the past years
is why don't we try
to learn a program?
I say it's come onto the
scene in recent years.
That's not exactly true.
People have been interested
in learning programs
for many, many years,
for many, many decades,
but they sort of
try to infer them
from kind of a
logical perspective,
not really getting these
probabilistic learning
algorithms.
I'm sort of throwing
words out there,
but it'll make more
sense as I go through it.
And you already have
some of Josh's stuff
to carry you through.
But the point is, there's
always these questions
of learning and representation.
For probabilistic
programming languages,
the representation is
not circles and arrows,
it's not vectors of
weights, it is programs.
That's what you're
trying to learn.
That's what you're trying to
figure out the world with.
And then there's
a question of how
do you learn these programs,
but we'll get to that.
OK, let's see, so we think it's
a good representation for AI
and cognition for
all the reasons
that Josh just talked about.
And there's been
a growing interest
in these things for
the past 10 years,
witnessed both by
the proliferation
of many, many different types
of programming languages--
sorry, probabilistic
programming languages.
I don't know whether to
call them PPL, or people,
or what exactly.
But probabilistic
programming languages,
there's been PyMC
based on Python,
there's Church,
which you're going
to play with right now, but
also BLOG, WinBUGS, ProbLog,
Venture, many others that
I haven't mentioned here.
So first of all,
there's many of them.
And also, DARPA has
started taking interest
and has given a large grant
to advance this field.
They think it might be big.
If you're in, sort of,
probabilistic programming more
generally than Church, you think
it's interesting to follow,
you want to learn more about
it, you should go to this thing,
probabilistic-programming.org
wiki.
It sort of keeps
it up-to-date with
many, many, many, different
types of programming languages.
You don't necessarily have
to write this down right now.
I will send you
the slides later,
but just, sort of,
keep it in mind form,
link to it in your head.
There's also this, sort of,
nice summary from this DARPA--
so DARPA started sending
this about a year ago.
And someone already
went to a summer school
on probabilistic
programming and, sort of,
wrote the state of the field.
It's six months ago.
It's a bit outdated,
but it also makes
for an interesting
read for those of you
who want to follow that.
OK, so that's about
probabilistic programming,
very, very, very generally.
What about Church very,
very, very generally?
So as I said, Church
is one example
of a probabilistic
programming language.
It was developed
by several people
at MIT who have
since gone on to do
other different
things like continue
to develop Church at Stanford.
That's Professor Noah Goodman.
Although, of course, he's
doing many, many other things.
There's also been
Vikash Mansinghka,
who has gone on to develop
other probabilistic programming
languages like Venture at MIT.
And one thing to say generally
about probabilistic programming
languages is that,
usually they are
based on an already
existing language.
So you take MATLAB and you
try to make it probabilistic.
You take Python and you try
to make it probabilistic.
Julia has a probabilistic
programming implementation.
Church in particular
is based on Scheme,
which is the derivative
of LISP, which is itself
sort of an attempt to capture
lambda calculus, which is not
a programming language,
it is an approach
to trying to think about all
possible functions developed
by Alonzo Church.
And that's why Church
is called Church.
It has nothing to do with
the actual buildings.
So the point about
Scheme which is very nice
is that it's very compositional.
And anything that
you write can then
be passed off into the
other functions as the data.
You'll see some
examples of that.
Church has several
inference engines
that you can try to run.
We'll get into that.
The backbone of it is
Metropolis-Hastings-type
sampling over possible
programs, but it
has other types of programming,
including explicit enumeration.
If your space is
small enough, it
can just look at all the
possible ways to run a program.
It has rejection query.
Again, we'll get to this.
Don't worry about, like,
what is he talking about.
Yeah, so it has a
whole bunch of-- you
know, particle filtering
is one attempt at that.
But the point is there are--
each probabilistic
programming language
has its own set of
inference engine.
Some of them try to go the
Metropolis-Hastings route.
Some of them try
to say, well, it's
a probabilistic
programming language,
but it's really limited
to causal Bayes nets,
so the inference
engines are going
to be stuff that's good
for causal Bayes nets.
But all of them sort
of share this dream of,
it's easier to write the forward
model than the inference.
And it's really annoying.
Those of you who have ever tried
to write an inference engine
or to write inference
over any sort of model,
it's really annoying
to write that.
And it usually sort of only
works for the one thing
that you've built.
And one of the selling
points of probabilistic
programming languages,
one of the reasons
that DARPA took
an interest, beyond the fact
that they can try to capture
the human mind, and flexible
AI, and all that, is they
have this sort of promise,
this pitch that, why don't you
just write down
the forward model,
how you think the world works,
and we'll, kind of, take
care of inference for you.
And in many cases,
it turns out to be
a lot easier to write
the forward model
than to try to write the
inference engine for it.
In fact, you can
very quickly get
to something that's even, like,
five or six lines of code long,
that would be intractable,
would be very hard to write down
the analytic
expression for, would
be very hard to think
about what would
be the inference engine for, but
it's really just easy to write.
I mean, all you have is
a set of assumptions.
And you're trying to figure
out how they work together.
Again, we'll see some
examples of that.
But my point was all
probabilistic programming
languages are about writing the
forward model and then, sort
of, trying to do the
inference for you.
Another point about
Church in particular,
it is under construction,
so you'll notice
this when you write it now.
It will break.
It will freeze.
It will do all sorts
of annoying things,
so it is under construction.
It's not exactly something
that you would then go and work
with like MATLAB.
Let me put some caveats on
that caveat, which is these two
asterisks right here.
First of all, despite being
a, sort of, a toy language,
it's already been used in
several serious scientific
papers, including
a paper in Science,
because it is very easy to make
certain points about cognition
or about computational
cognition in Church that
is very hard to do in
certain other languages.
In particular, things that
require recursion, or inference
over inference, where you
write down sort of the way
that you think about
an agent, then you
put that into
another agent, that
can be very hard to write
in certain languages.
Church can kind of
do that more easily.
Let's see, I had another
caveat, which is--
what was that?
Oh, another caveat
is that, despite it
being under construction, you
sort of think, well, why should
I worry about this thing?
Why should I even
bother hacking with it?
Is because, you'll notice
there's probmods.org.
And there are just a
ton, a ton of examples.
There's a semester
worth of examples
of all sorts of things from
both cognition, and AI,
and interesting
statistical models
that are very easy to
understand in Church.
And for me at least,
it was very much
a process of demystification
that something like this
can help with.
You learn about something
like the Chinese restaurant
process, the Dirichlet
process, nonparametrics,
and it's kind of hard to read
the textbook description of it.
It's hard to wrap
your head around.
And then you go and you
write three lines of code,
or five lines of code.
And you think, oh, that
wasn't so bad, right?
And it's sort of
easy to write a bunch
of these things in Church,
so it's a useful tool
for demystification.
It's a useful tool
to get a handle
on certain models in
cognition and statistics,
so those are the two asterisks.
Be warned, but also, you
know, do play around with it.
Let's see, the founding
paper, for those of you
who are interested, you can
look at this link later on.
It was by Goodman,
Mansinghka, Dan Roy, Bonawitz,
and Tenenbaum.
And for those of
you who, by the way,
have already read
about Church a bit,
you think that this tutorial
is a bit-- maybe it was--
I should say, we'll start
off very, very easy, OK?
We'll do things like addition.
We'll do things like
flipping coins, OK?
If you think that this is--
maybe you've already
read through probmods,
you've already done a few
chapters of that, by all means,
use this time to
continue to think
about probabilistic
programming, for example,
either by talking
to me, and I'll
find something for you, or
by going to forestdb.org.
Again, I'll give you that link
for those of you who want it.
It has a whole repository
of different probabilistic
programming models that you
can play with, think about, see
how you would change them,
and things like that.
Also after this tutorial,
if you're still interested,
you can go to that link.
Oh and one last thing.
There's sort of a-- you
can't see that right there.
One last thing that I
should say about Church,
it's based on Scheme.
But a lot of the people
that have sort of been
doing a lot of work
on it have become
more in love with JavaScript.
In fact, the thing that
you're going to be working on
is sort of a JavaScript
implementation
of Church under the hood.
And they've started to implement
something called WebPPL, so
Web Probabilistic
Programming Language.
It's a language
that's specifically
a derivative of JavaScript.
For those of you
who like JavaScript,
you can play with that.
And if you go to WebPPL.org,
if you search for WebPPL,
again, I can leave
you the link for that.
It's sort of here,
but you can't see it.
There are, again, a lot
of nice examples there
of different programming
language-- programs
that you can write
in JavaScript.
OK, that was a very
long-winded introduction,
caveats, and setting
up different things.
The objectives for this
tutorial is, first of all,
to become familiar
with the Church syntax,
it can be a little wonky, if you
don't know it, at first, to run
forward a few models to
give you an example of just,
before inference, an example
of, here's my forward model,
here's how I describe the world,
now let's try sampling from it.
Let's sample, sample
again, sample again,
sample again, see what
distributions we get.
Get a sense for
the point that I'm
going to make a few times,
which is once you write
your forward model,
that is a representation
of a distribution--
and I'll come back
to this point,
but just, sort of,
keep that in mind.
You write down a program.
And you run it forward.
And you get a sample.
You run it again and you
get a different sample.
You run it in the limit,
you get some distribution.
Some other constructs
like memoization--
after we do all
of this, we'll try
to get at sampling, and the
query operator, and really,
conditioning and inference.
So we said we'll try to
run a few models forward.
Once we do that, we'll try
to get the hang of inference.
So you'll try to write down
a forward model about things
like a coin, or goal
inference, or things like that.
And you'll try to
actually infer something,
like what is the
weight of the coin,
from some data, like some coin
flips, some very simple stuff.
OK, and we'll go through some
examples, like, as I said,
coin flipping, maybe causal
networks, maybe intuitive
physics and
intuitive psychology.
I do hope to get to
We'll see if we get to that.
So some prerequisites
and set up,
that's what I asked you
to do at the beginning.
If you happen to have
a local implementation,
you can open that now.
If you didn't, just go to
probmods.org/play-space.html
and open that up.
And we're going to play a
game of Noisy Tomer Says.
So now you should also--
open this, open a
browser, go to that,
or open your local
implementation.
Also open up the file
that I sent you of--
it should have have been
called, like, student copy,
something like that.
It contains a bunch of
things that we're basically
going to just sort of copy,
paste into the browser.
Now, the nice thing
about this browser
is, it is sort of a working
implementation of Church.
You just paste in the code.
You hit run.
It runs, OK?
So you guys should all more or
less have a screen like this.
I'll take this out so I
don't sit on it right now.
Does everyone have
more or less something
like this, some sort
of browser that you can
type things into and press run?
Over there?
OK, we'll start off with
some very, very simple stuff
that you should already have
in the syntax of the Church
tutorial, so just try
either pasting in or typing
in things like this thing.
So the first thing you'll
notice is that, over here, it's
what's called--
sorry, let me adjust this
screen so it's not actually--
so that you can see it.
Zone C over here, you
should be looking--
I've sort of done over here,
plus 2 2, and the result is 4.
So the first thing
to see, some of you
may be familiar with this, who's
somebody with Polish notation,
where you just go plus 2 2?
Instead of going 2 plus--
who is not familiar
with Polish notation?
OK, good, thank you.
Polish notation just means that,
instead of writing 2 plus 2,
you write plus 2 2, so you write
that the thing that operates,
the function, outside, and
you write all the arguments
for the function like that.
In fact, most of the
time, you do this.
When you write down
functions for code,
you usually write the
function then the things
that it operates on.
But here, it's going
to work for everything.
And it can be a bit
confusing at first
when you do things
like plus 2 2.
The second thing is that
you put brackets on anything
that you want to evaluate, OK?
So, for example, here
is an expression.
The expression is plus 2 2.
And you want to evaluate
that expression.
So for example, I wanted to
evaluate the expression--
I think I put some,
like, cursor for--
so you can see what I'm
doing with my thing.
OK, if you want to do something
like, you know, times 2 2,
that would be the same thing.
And I would go to run.
And that would be,
of course, 4 again.
It let's you do some
other examples from here.
Like there's a bunch
of simple logic,
like you might do display.
Display is just a way
to run it, to-- sorry,
to display the result over here.
You can do a bunch of
logic things, like equal.
So again, the
operator is outside.
And you would do equal
question mark 2 2,
and then evaluate
that expression.
And you can do
bigger than equals,
all these different things.
AUDIENCE: the question mark?
TOMER ULLMAN: The
question mark is just--
I've just named it that way.
It doesn't actually
have any sense.
I could have just called it
equal-- sorry, no, sorry.
There is no particular
meaning to the question mark.
It's just that this
thing, this operator,
is called equal question mark.
That's the name for it.
And it's just-- it is
the equals operator.
That's how you check
if two things are
equal to one another.
In languages like
Python, you would
do, you know, equals
equals, like that.
This is how you do it here, OK?
Let's see, a few other
simple syntax things.
So you might say, for
example, the statement
for defining variables
is, shockingly enough,
define, so you
would do define x 3.
And now, the next time that
I do x, then hopefully--
and I run that--
then it'll show 3.
There are a few other
basic syntax things,
like lists, that might be
important, like, you know,
define x to be a list of 1 2 3.
And if you run that,
then you'll get 1 2 3.
Again, we're starting
out very, very slow,
but we'll hopefully
get soon to more things
like Gaussian processes.
Some simple things like
if-then statements--
OK, I'm just copying and
pasting off of this document
that you should
all have, so that's
why I'm, sort of,
running through it.
But the point is that
you would do-- the syntax
for doing an if-then conditional
statement is like this.
You write down if, and then
you write down the condition
that either evaluates
to true or to false.
So it's if this condition,
do the first thing.
If it's false, do
the second thing.
In this particular
case, I have defined
a variable called socrates.
I've defined it as drunk.
And then I run the condition
equal socrates drunk,
if that's true, then
return the answer true.
Or, you know, I could have
written return the answer,
Socrates is a drunk.
If it's false, return
the answer false.
Did everyone more or
less get the conditional?
It just says, if condition,
return the first thing
otherwise, the thing
on the second line.
Another important
thing before we
start getting at more
things like recursion
and forward sampling
is the notion of,
how would I define a function?
So, so far we've defined
variables, right?
I could have defined something
like define x 2, right?
And then that would
have just been that.
But I want to define,
probably, functions, so I might
define something like define--
and now I have two options.
There are two ways of
defining functions in Church.
One of them is to
do the following.
You define square.
And then you say, well, square
is, itself, a procedure.
It is a lambda.
And I'll explain this
as I go along, just
watch me, sort of, type it.
It takes in a particular
argument, say, x.
And then what it does to,
is it multiplies x by x.
So the point is, you say, well,
here, x is a particular thing.
It is an object.
What is it?
It is just 2.
Here, square is a thing.
What sort of thing is it?
It is this thing.
Ah, what is this thing?
This thing is a procedure that--
this is the only thing that you
need to know about functions.
Lambda is the thing that
actually defines functions, OK?
It is a procedure that takes
in some number of arguments,
in this case, just one argument.
You could have
called it anything.
I just called it x.
You could have
called it argument1.
called it socrates.
You could have called it fubar.
But the point is, it
takes in this argument.
And then what does it do
with it is the next thing?
So you say, lambda, number of
arguments that you take in.
And then what do you do with it?
In this case, you
just do times x x.
So this is a function called
square, very basic stuff.
It takes in an argument and
it multiplies it by itself,
so it is the square of x,
x times x, very simple.
There's another way of
doing that if you don't want
to type out lambdas,
if you don't want
to start doing lambda
this, lambda that,
it's sort of annoying.
Let me just give you
one more example.
Like, if I wanted something
with two arguments,
I could have done-- you know, I
could have called it something
like my-proc lambda x y.
And now, what it does
is, it multiplies xy.
OK, this is an
example of a thing.
What sort of thing is it?
It is a procedure.
I know it's a procedure
because it starts with lambda.
It takes in two arguments.
Here they're called x and y.
What does that do with it?
It multiplies x times y.
Really, this is
just multiplication.
So after I define
this procedure,
I could then do,
like, my-proc-- sorry,
I should have explained that.
Then you do my-proc, say, 2
8, or something like that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TOMER ULLMAN: Yeah, sorry--
that's a very good question.
And it would bring back 16.
Sorry, once I define my thing,
this is an operator now.
This is an operator that
can be applied to arguments.
And you apply it by doing that
parentheses that we just saw.
If I just tried, by the way,
like, without applying it,
if I just tried something like
this, what you would get back
is, it would say, this is a
function, because it just says,
what is this thing?
You try to evaluate it.
You're not evaluating on
anything, so it just returns,
what is this thing?
It's a function.
It's a function that expects
x y and then multiplies them.
If you actually want to
apply it on something,
you would need to provide
with some input arguments.
So I said, let's try to define
square as a lambda of x.
That does-- it takes in an
x and multiplies x by x.
There's one more way to
define a function, which,
it sort of gets rid of
this lambda type thing.
It's exactly equivalent to
the thing I just showed you,
it just takes a bit less
writing, which is to say,
define--
I just misspelled
square, didn't I?
Yes.
Define square x-- like that--
times x x.
Now what this is
saying, so this just
goes straight to saying,
like, before I would say,
define this thing 2.
OK, and then I said, define
this thing, the square,
as this procedure.
Here you can say, I want to
directly define a procedure.
I'm not going to bother
with this lambda stuff.
I want to directly
define a function.
define a procedure.
Can I do that?
Yes, you could if you wanted to.
You would just directly put
these brackets right there.
You would say define.
And if the next thing is
some brackets, then it says,
OK, I'm going to
define a procedure
where the name of the
procedure is square.
And it takes in one
argument, which is x.
And what it does
to it is times x x.
And if you do it that
way, then under the hood,
what Scheme does is actually
writes it out like this.
It puts in the lambda
where it expects,
but again, this is not
terribly important stuff.
And those of you are,
sort of, tuning out,
and saying, well, fine.
And you just wanted to
learn about-- a bit more
about how probabilistic
programming works, don't worry.
We'll get to some examples
in about 10 minutes.
Here's another very useful
thing that you might want
to do in many of your things.
This is called the map.
And the way map works
is, you map a function
to a bunch of arguments.
So you would say--
map is just a
high-level function
which takes in a
particular procedure.
Then it applies it to each one
of these things individually,
OK?
So square, in this
case, as we said,
it is a thing that
takes in one argument.
So this is now going to take
square and apply it to 1.
So then I'm going to take
square and apply it to 2,
take square and apply it to 3.
And the result of
this is just going
to be a list of squares, 1
4, 9, 16, 25, simple enough?
Yes.
But map is very useful.
You should probably
know about it.
OK, some simple things
like, recursion, OK,
so suppose I wanted to
apply square to the list
from 1 to 100, and suppose I
didn't have the range 1 to 100.
Most languages in
Scheme actually
does have something called
range, which gives you
all the numbers from 1 to 100.
Suppose I didn't.
Suppose I want to construct
all the numbers 1 to 100.
I don't want to actually
write them down--
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, all
the way up to 100.
I can write down
something that does that.
And it uses a little
bit of recursion.
And the way it does it is this.
This is just to get
you used to recursion,
because we'll be seeing
it a little bit later.
And this says, OK, I'm going to
define something called range,
which takes in an argument--
you should now be used to it,
this is the same thing
that we defined over here.
We're going to call
something a procedure.
And we're going to call--
we're going to
define a procedure.
It's called range.
It takes in an argument,
n, one argument.
What does it do?
Well, it depends.
It does a conditional.
A conditional, it depends,
let's see, is n equal to 0?
If it's 0, just give
me back an empty list.
Does everyone sort of
see that, if equal n 0,
give me back a list.
What if it's not 0?
What if I did range 10?
Oh, well, in that case, append--
another thing that you might
want to know, so it's just
combine these two things--
append what with what?
Append range again with
n minus 1 and with n.
The point here is
to say, OK, how
do I get the numbers 1 to 100?
I just, sort of, say range--
I want the range 1 to 100, so
I say, 100-- am I at 0 yet?
No, so take 100 and
append it with range 99.
What does range 99 do?
Well, is 99 0?
No, so give me
back 99 plus what?
Plus range 98.
Is 98 0?
No, keep going, so it's
basically recursing-- range
is a recursive function
that calls itself until it
hits 0, very simple recursion.
And now you can do
this to write out
all the numbers from 1 to 100.
And then you, if you
were so inclined,
you could do math
square to that.
OK, and we run that.
And it gives me all the
numbers from-- the squares
of the numbers from 1 to 100.
So far we've talked just
about very basic stuff.
This is no different
from Scheme.
You are all experts in Scheme
notation and things like that.
Let's move on to something a
little bit more interesting
that Church can do, which
is, for example, take
random sequences, and
it can take random--
how should I put this?
Kind of like plus is a basic
thing in certain programming
languages, it's a
primitive, right?
It's written into
the language what
plus means, what times means.
You don't have to define that.
The way most languages
work is that they
have this sort of
long list of things
that they need to evaluate.
And they start evaluating them.
And they're, sort of, OK, did
I hit an expression I know,
like a number or not?
And it's, sort of, no,
you didn't hit it yet.
OK, fine, keep evaluating,
keep evaluating,
keep evaluating until you
get some sort of primitive.
And a primitive procedure
could be something
like plus or a number.
In Church, there are
primitive procedures
which are random
primitive procedures.
They are procedures
that, when you hit them,
what you do is, you just return
a value, a sampled value,
from this expression, from
this probability distribution.
So the most basic
random primitive,
the most basic distribution
that you can do in Church
is something called flip.
And if you just write
down flip in Church,
what you'll get, if you run
it like that, is it tells you,
well, it's a function.
And it depends on
certain arguments.
And it tells you many,
many things about it,
but that's not what we want.
We want to evaluate it, so put
some parentheses around it.
And we'll run it.
And it will give us back false.
OK, let's try that again.
So let's run that again.
It will gave us back
true, OK, interesting.
And if we run that again,
you know, we get false.
We run it again, and we get
maybe true, maybe false.
You could do repeat
1,000 times flip.
OK, repeat is another
important thing
that you would need to know.
It just says repeat
as many times
as you want to repeat
some sort of function.
In this case, the
function is flip.
OK, so repeat flip 1,000 times.
I hope you guys are trying
this while I'm saying this.
Are people trying
this more or less?
OK, cool.
So repeat 1,000 times flip.
And what you'll get
back is this long list
of true, false, true, false,
false, true, false, true.
And it's independent
from one another,
because it's an exchangeable
random sequence.
And if you want to see
what this looks like,
well, you could just
do something like hist.
And you would run that.
And you would get, you
know, more or less 50-50.
Not exactly 50-50, because
I only ran it 1,000 times.
If I had run this in the
limit, what I would get
is 50-50 on true-false.
Now, what's nice about this
is that this sort of gets
at this thing that I was talking
about earlier, where there's
dual representation for any sort
of probability distribution.
You could either write the
probability distribution
in math.
You could sort of say, well,
the probability of true is 0.5.
And the probability
of false is 0.5.
Now I've defined a
distribution in math.
And now you can
say, well, what's
conditioned on this, what can
you do, and things like that.
Or what you can do is, you
can write a program such that,
when you run it, it will
sample one of these values.
And in the limit,
it samples it's such
that it approximated the thing
that we just defined in math.
And you might say, well, why
not just define it in math?
Because oftentimes, it gets
very, very, hairy very, very
fast.
And in fact, any sort of
probability distribution
that's well-defined
and well-behaved,
you can write as a program.
A program which, if you run
it many times, its sampling
profile, the thing it will give
you back if you sample it many,
many different times,
will give you back
that probability distribution.
Or you could
equivalently say that,
what it means for a
probability distribution
to be a probability distribution
is to be some sort of program,
to be some sort of procedure
that gives you back a sample.
And in the limit, you
get some sort of thing
that we're going to call the
probability distribution.
Actually, that's the way
we define the probability
distribution.
And again, this
gets in-- so one way
to think about Church programs
is that any Church program
that you write-- if you
just write plus 2 2,
you'll get back 4.
That's, in a way, a
deterministic program, right?
The probability of getting back
4 on this execution equals 1,
but there are many other
things that you could write
and you could get back
interesting things for them.
And the point is
to write something
like a generative model that
describes some sort of thing
about the world.
And when you run it forward,
you get to a certain sample,
but if you run in many,
many different times,
it gives you the
probability distribution
that this model describes.
And now, if you-- and again,
I'm getting slightly ahead
of myself.
If you change that model,
if you, for example,
condition on something,
you'll get a different model.
You'll get a different program.
And you're trying to
find the program such
that its output
will match the data.
OK, but let's back
up a little bit.
And we're still in flip land.
So we have here
something which is flip.
That's very, very basic.
Flip can also be--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TOMER ULLMAN: OK.
Flip can also be a biased coin.
So for example, if I do--
I define something
like, you know, define--
let's do this
slightly differently.
Let's call this
lambda something.
And what it does is flip 0.9.
So if you run this forward,
what you'll get now
is that flip can actually
take in some arguments.
If you don't give
it any arguments,
it'll just do flip 50-50.
If you give it some
arguments, it'll
do flip a biased coin, where
the coin is biased towards 0.9.
And you can see that, after
I repeated that 1,000 times,
I get, you know, it's
approximately 90% heads,
or true, and about 10% tails.
AUDIENCE: Why did you
make the lambda in there?
TOMER ULLMAN: Ah,
perfect, I'm glad somebody
has asked that question.
So if I were just to do
the following-- suppose
that I were just do
repeat flip 0.9 like that,
think about what would happen.
What would happen is, I would
first evaluate flip 0.9.
OK, that would give me back a
value, either true or false.
And then this would say,
repeat that 1,000 times.
You would get, like, 1,000
trues, or 1,000 falses,
or whatever it was
that was first.
In fact, it's going to
fail, because repeat
expects a function.
But the point is, the reason
that this is going to fail
is because it wants a
particular function.
This is not a function,
this is a value.
You evaluate this first.
It gives you a value
like true or false.
And then you repeat
that value 1,000 times.
That's not what you want.
What you want is a procedure.
A procedure, or a distribution,
or something like that,
some sort of function
that, when you run it,
you get a biased sample, so
what would that look like?
That would look like this.
It would be-- or I could
do something like this.
Define my-coin weight--
OK, something like this.
And what it does is this.
Now what I've defined is,
I've defined a procedure that
takes in a particular weight.
And what it does is
that it gives you
back a flip on that weight.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TOMER ULLMAN: Yes,
although you might, again,
run into some problems, but
we can get to that, because--
well, OK.
So let's see--
AUDIENCE: How would define
it as a lambda calculus?
TOMER ULLMAN: OK, so how you
would define it with the lambda
calculus is, you would
say my-coin lambda
weight this thing.
OK, now we're saying, what
sort of thing is coin?
Coin is a procedure.
How do we know it's a procedure?
Because we have this
lambda right here.
How many arguments
does it expect?
One, it's called weight.
What does it do?
It flips a coin.
It gives you back that sample.
AUDIENCE: Can I do--
TOMER ULLMAN: The
equivalent way of doing
that is by writing this
thing without any lambdas.
You would just write
define my-coin--
notice the brackets
there, right?
Before we didn't have brackets
around that-- define my-coin
weight flip weight, like that.
And now you're sort of saying,
like, this is a procedure.
You should know it's a
procedure, because it's
the first thing that you're
hitting after define because
of the parentheses.
What sort of procedure is it?
It's called my-coin.
It takes in weight.
Again, these are equivalent.
And to answer Nori's question
about how would I just do
that without having
to define things,
I would say something
like, hist repeat 1,000.
Now, what do I want to repeat?
I want to repeat some sort of
procedure that samples things.
So it's-- I'll call it lambda.
It's an empty lambda.
It doesn't take
in any arguments.
It's just the procedure.
And what it does is,
it flips a coin 0.9.
And if I run that,
I'll get that.
OK, yes, no?
OK, good.
OK, so let's see, there
are many other primitives
that we could get to.
There is uniform-draw.
You can look at this
online, but there's--
the basic primitives
are things like
multinomial, uniform, random
integer, beta, Dirichlet,
there's also the Chinese
restaurant process.
So let's see, we can build in
our own little distribution.
OK, let's try doing that.
So here I've defined something
which, under the hood,
it's actually-- it's an
interesting distribution.
You all probably know it.
But the way I'm
going to define it
is, I'm going to call it
times it counts until heads.
This is a procedure that's
going to flip a coin.
And if it comes up--
it's going to flip a coin
with a particular weight.
If it comes up true,
if it comes up heads,
then it's just going to stop.
It's going to give you back 0.
If it doesn't stop, if
it comes back tails,
it's going to tell you that.
It's going to write
down somewhere, like, 1.
And it's going to keep going.
It's going to recurse somehow,
call itself, and then keep
going.
So this is for you, this
is an exercise for you.
You have it under
the files, under 3.4,
build your own distribution.
I've left this open.
Why don't you take two minutes.
We're trying to build a
procedure that gives me
the amount of times that I
need to flip a coin before I
get back heads, OK?
If I take a particular coin--
I guess I don't want
to have one handy--
but I flip a coin.
And I just-- you
know, I flip it.
If it comes back heads, I
write down 0 and I'm done.
If it comes back tails, I'm
going to keep flipping it,
so I flip it again.
And you know, I might flip it
10 times until I get heads,
so the point is that this
procedure will, in that case,
return 10.
That would be one
particular sample.
Now, of course, if I take the
coin again and I flip it again,
sometimes I get 10 times
until heads, sometimes once,
sometimes 5,
sometimes 20, so I'm
going to get a
particular distribution
on the number of times I
need until I hit heads.
And the thing that we're
trying to implement right now
is just a procedure
that, what it does is,
it implements this
counting thing that I just
said by literally
flipping a coin-- well,
I don't know if literally,
but under the hood,
flipping a coin.
If the coin comes back heads,
because this thing evaluates
to true, give back 0.
If it doesn't, give
back plus 1 plus what?
So fill in those
dots-- it shouldn't
be a long expression--
such that you'll get
what I was just talking about.
So, guys, let me tell
you what I was going for.
An int plus 1
countsTillHeads coinweight.
OK, and now if you do
something like countsTillHeads,
I don't know, 0.1 or something
like that, and you run it.
And it gets saved--
so let's read through
this for a second.
What happens is, you
defined a procedure.
It's called countsTillHeads.
It takes in a coin weight.
It flips a coin.
If it comes back head,
it gives you back 0.
If it didn't come back heads,
then you just do plus 1.
And then you just
call that thing again.
You do countTillHeads
coinweight again and again.
If it comes back 0, then this
time, you'll have plus 1 plus 0
if it came back heads in here.
But if it didn't, then this
will be plus 1 plus something.
In effect, what
we've defined here--
those of you that have
defined it, and if not,
just look at this--
what you've defined here
is sort of a procedure that
might give us back
infinity in some way,
except it's becoming
extremely unlikely to do so
with each particular
flip of the coin.
Now, I run it once with 0.1.
I get 15.
I can run it again and
I'll get, you know, 8.
That just means
that, on that run,
I flipped it eight times
before I got heads.
And again, I can do this
many, many different times.
Like, I can do hist repeat
1,000 and then this thing,
some empty procedure
that does that.
And what you gets is
this, which, in case it
doesn't look
familiar-- sorry, it's
just the way these
things usually look.
This is sort of flipping
the x- and y-axis.
But the point is,
how many times did I
have to flip it to get, you
know-- how many times did it
happen?
Did I flip it three times,
or one, or two, three times?
That's about 24%.
And it sort of goes
down, and down, and down,
because it becomes much,
much, much more unlikely
that I'll flip it 40
times until I get heads.
It could be that I'll keep
flipping it to infinity,
but it's not going to happen.
This, in case you didn't
know, falls off geometrically.
It's the geometric distribution.
That's a very fundamental,
simple distribution.
And one way to
write it is to say,
what's the probability of k?
The probability of k is--
let's say, we have a
coin which has the--
it's probability of
coming up heads is p.
Then we say the
probability of k is
p to the k minus 1
times 1 minus p, yes?
It's I flip the coin 1
minus p times to the k.
The point is, you can define the
geometric distribution by sort
of saying, what's
the probability
of any particular number?
Or you can define the
procedure for it, OK?
Instead of writing
down what should
be the probability of
any particular sequence,
you can just write down the
procedure that it describes.
This is the procedure.
The procedure doesn't
explicitly tell you
what the distribution
is, it just samples it.
You've built a procedure
for flipping a coin.
And if you do it many,
many, many different times,
what you'll get is the
geometric distribution.
This is will approach the
I can probably also do
density, and then it'll
show you it like that.
So that's what I was talking
about before with, like,
trying to wrap your
head around something
like the equivalence between
a probability distribution
that you can write down in math
or as an analytical expression
and writing down the equivalent
procedure for generating
that probability distribution.
Let's move on to something a
little bit more interesting
like Gaussian sampling.
If you're not with
us, you can look at it
in 3.5, Gaussian Samples.
What I've done here
is, basically, I'm
defining a particular center.
Let's walk through
this for a second.
I'm defining a
two-dimensional Gaussian.
What it does is, it takes
a particular center.
A center is just an x-y point.
And it does, you know,
Gaussian around the first one.
I'm trying to define a
two-dimensional Gaussian.
The way I do it
is, I take a point
around-- a one-dimensional
Gaussian around this point.
And I take a
one-dimensional Gaussian
around the second point.
And then I just draw it.
So in this particular case,
I'm going to define my Gaussian
center as 3, 2.
OK, I'm going to take it
x equals 3, y equals 2.
And I want to sample a
Gaussian around 3, 2.
So I'm going to sample
of Gaussian around 3
and a Gaussian around 2.
And I'm going to
give you that back.
And if I repeat this 1,000
times, then-- and I scatter it,
I'll end up with a plot
that looks a bit like this.
And you can see on
the x-axis, this is 3.
And this is 2.
And it's basically a
Gaussian with sampling points
from around this thing,
another forward procedure
that I can sample.
OK, is everyone more or
less on board with this?
Let's take two seconds
to read this again.
A basic procedure in
Church is Gaussian.
What I do is I basically--
I try to call Gaussian
on some number.
Gaussian takes in two arguments.
Gaussian takes in a
mean and a variance.
In particular, I'm going
to take a Gaussian.
And its mean is going to be
the first argument of center.
Its variance it's going to be 1.
I'm going to take
a Gaussian sampled
from the second argument,
the y, and a variance of 1.
And then I'm going to just
give you back to that point.
So this is a procedure that
takes in a center point.
And each time you sample it,
it will give you a sample
from around the mean 3, 2.
And if I run that--
so now I've defined
a particular center.
You know, I've defined it 3, 2.
I could have done many
other different things.
And I repeat that 100 times.
I've basically drawn a sample
from something around 3, 2.
This can quickly get more
interesting if you do something
like a mixture of Gaussians.
So a Gaussian mixture model
is usually just saying, OK,
I have some particular space.
And I'm trying to figure
out how many Gaussians
are in this scene, so let's
write down the forward model
for that thing.
What's the forward model
for a mixture model?
The forward model saying,
I'm going to draw out
some number of Gaussians.
I don't know how many.
And I don't
necessarily know what
their center point is, right?
And from each one
of these, I'm going
to draw some number of samples.
Does everyone understand,
more or less, that description
that I just gave?
We're going to write it out now.
But the point is,
the generative model
in your head for a
mixture of Gaussians
should be, there are
some number of Gaussians.
I don't know what it is.
Each one of them is
centered on some point.
I don't know what it is.
Let's say I know the
variance just for simplicity,
but I could obviously
put a prior on that.
And then I just
sample from that.
And I'll get some distribution.
And then you could use--
we'll later on see,
once you write down
that forward model,
it's pretty simple to then
just invert it and say,
OK, I see some number of points.
How many Gaussians
are there actually?
But let's write down
the forward model.
So I have already done
this ahead of time.
And I'll do it here.
So what I've done here,
minus the typo, thanks,
is to say something like, I
want a sample of Gaussian center
where I don't know
where it is, but I'm
going to say that it's in this
two-dimensional space between 0
and 10, a box that's
10 wide and 10 tall.
So for each new Gaussian, I
don't know where its center is,
but I'm assuming it's
somewhere in this box
that we're looking at.
And the way I do
that is, I say, OK, I
define some sort of procedure.
Each time you evaluate
this procedure, what
it's going to give
you back is a pair,
where the first
thing in the pair
is a uniform between 0 and 10,
the second thing in the pair
is a uniform between 0 and 10.
If all you were to do are
to sample Gaussian center,
you would get back some number
uniformly-distributed in the 10
box, where the first
one is, let's say,
x, and the second one is y.
And the next thing
I do is, let's say
I want to define some
number of Gaussians
and I don't know
how many there are.
Let's say, for
example, that I want
to put some sort of ignorance
prior on Gaussians between--
there might be one, there might
be two, there might be 10.
Let's say I stop it at 10
or something like that.
So in this case, I just say,
sample the number of Gaussians
from something like random
integer 10, since this
goes to 0, and you
don't want 0, I'm
just adding the number 1 here.
But what I also could
have done, and I
think I was going to
do this is an exercise,
but since we want to get
to physics, and psychology,
and some more interesting stuff,
what I could have done here
is define number of Gaussians--
suppose I wanted to
put a prior on there
being potentially an
infinite number of Gaussian,
what would I do?
AUDIENCE: Dirichlet.
TOMER ULLMAN: A
Dirichlet, right?
Or what else can I do that
we've already learned?
We could do the
geometric, right?
We just defined the
geometric a second ago.
The geometric gives
us a probability
on numbers basically
going from 0 to infinity.
And it dies off very
quickly, so this gives us
sort of a natural prior
of some sort to say,
I think that there are some
number of Gaussians here.
I don't know what it is.
I'm pretty sure it dies off.
Like, I don't think 100 is
as equally likely as 10.
I don't think 10 is as
equally likely as 1.
So I could have said,
define number of Gaussians,
just draw from geometric.
And then I would have gotten
some number, potentially
infinite.
You've just defined an infinite
Gaussian mixture model.
And then I draw some
number of centers
by basically repeating
this procedure.
I sample the Gaussians.
And then I scatter the points.
Let's see, and then you
can look at the points.
And this is a fun game to play.
It's basically recapturing a
bit of what Josh said before,
which is to say,
how many Gaussians
do you think are in this image?
And you can sort of
play that with yourself
to get a sense of it.
You know, you've
defined some procedure.
You don't know how many
Gaussians you actually created.
You don't know exactly
where they are,
but you can run it forward.
And you can look at it
and say, well, here I
think it's pretty obvious.
I think there's
sort of a Gaussian
here, maybe a Gaussian here.
So I guess the number
here is 2, but here it's
a bit less obvious.
And again, you can
play with this.
So those of you who've
written this down,
and assuming you've
done either a Dirichlet
or a geometric distribution
what you've basically done
is written down the forward
model for an infinite Gaussian
mixture model.
And you did it in, more or
less, five lines of code.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What is
the fold there?
TOMER ULLMAN: Where
do you see fold here?
AUDIENCE: Visualize
scatter fold append
TOMER ULLMAN: Ah,
yes, so fold is
another high-level procedure.
It's not terribly important for
the purposes of this tutorial,
but what it does is, it
basically takes in a function.
It takes in a list of stuff.
And it basically applies
it to the first argument.
Then it takes it and
applies it to whatever
the result was plus
the next item--
AUDIENCE: Plus?
TOMER ULLMAN: --in the list.
Well, not exactly plus--
AUDIENCE: In addition?
TOMER ULLMAN: --but,
yes, in addition,
so you can have
a fold which has,
for example, two arguments.
And what it does
is it multiplies.
So then you would take a list.
And you would basically do--
or rather, what is sum.
what some is basically is
a fold of plus over a list,
because it takes
the first number,
sums it up with the second
one, takes that result,
sums it up with a third one--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TOMER ULLMAN: Fold
needs three arguments.
Fold needs a particular--
well, it needs the function
that you're going to apply.
It needs a starting
point to start from.
And it needs a lot that
it's going to work on,
again, not terribly
important for--
AUDIENCE: So why do this?
TOMER ULLMAN: So in
this particular case,
what I'm trying to
do in the background
is, I'm going to get
a lot of Gaussians.
I don't know how many.
I'm going to get
basically a list of lists.
It could be one.
It could be three.
It could be 10.
Each one of them is going to
define some number of points.
And I just want to scatter them.
But scatter works by
taking in one list,
so it's basically just
a way of collapsing.
Say I have three, or 10,
I don't know how many.
I'm trying to collapse
some number of lists
into a single list.
We've defined some
number of Gaussians.
This is a London Blitz example.
Josh was talking about
this a little bit.
Those of you who want to,
sort of, jump back in again,
you can go to 3.5.2 in
the student document.
You can copy and whatever
is under that and paste it.
And let's talk about that
example for a second.
What this thing is doing is,
it's sort of Josh's example--
do you remember his example
of, we have some sort of grid.
And we're trying
to say, is there
a suspicious cluster
somewhere, a disease cluster?
We have some dots.
And we're trying to
figure out is there
something going on here?
You know, there's sort of
a faulty, I don't know,
whatever, asbestos or
something like that.
And I want to figure that out.
So what you're going to
get is sort of a 2D map.
You're going to get
some dots from that map.
And you're trying to figure
out-- your hypothesis is either
this is sort of
randomly-distributed,
it's a uniform, or there's
some sort of center here.
So how do we write down the
forward model for something
like that?
We would write down either--
the particular
example, I'm doing
here is another example
that Tom Griffiths did,
which is, during the Blitz,
during the London bombing--
this is actually a very old
example of finding patterns.
Some of the British,
the people of London,
were convinced that there
were spies in London that
were telling the Germans where
to bomb during the Blitz.
And the way that they
reasoned this is,
they looked at the
pattern of bombings.
And they said, there's no
way that this is random.
They just looked at,
like, dots on a map.
And to them, it looked
a bit like Gaussians,
or things like that.
They were working from,
sort of, few examples.
When you look at, there's, sort
of, these nice web-- "nice,"
I don't know if it's nice--
but there's these websites that
show you the entire
Blitz from when
it started to when it ended.
And it's basically a
random distribution.
If you run statistical
tests on it,
it's no different from
a random distribution.
How would you run
such a test on it?
What you would do,
for example, is
you would write a forward model
that says it's either random,
uniform, or it's not.
Now, tell me which
one is more likely.
And that's what people
have, kind of, done.
That's a nice data set
to play around with.
The way that we've
written it over here
is to say, look, we
have two options.
Either it's a uniform bombing
or it's some targeted bombing.
The uniform bombing is
basically going to give us
just some point between 0--
between this box of 0 to
10, just this thing that we
were talking about before.
It's going to sample
uniformly from this box.
The targeted bombing is going
to sample some Gaussians,
just like we defined before.
You don't know how many.
You don't know
where the center is.
And it's going to then
sample from those Gaussians.
And it's going to give you
back some sort of scatter.
And you're basically
going to say, OK,
I don't know if it's
random, uniform,
or if there's some targeted
bombing going on here,
so I'm going to place,
basically, some inference.
I'm going to flip a coin.
If it comes up heads, I'm
going to do uniform bombing.
If it comes up tails, I'm
going to do targeted bombing.
And then you could look
at something like this.
And you can say,
well, I don't know.
That's kind of odd.
I mean, it doesn't exactly
look like a uniform bombing.
There's all this missing
empty space over here, right?
It doesn't exactly look
like one particular target.
And again, you can
sort of play with this.
And we'll get into the inference
about how to invert this thing.
But just as a forward model,
you can play with this,
run it forward, and try
to see if you can guess.